hello everyone I'm having the worst
toothache but my dentist assures me that
that is the feeling of healing I'm
experiencing so annoying as it is it's
no reason not to show a nice game
between Peter Svidler and Vaslav on Joe
it's a game from round 13 of the 2013
candidates tournament we've already seen
one game the Crossland versus the job of
game were cross and defeated team order
Java and once again established his lead
in the tournament we will talk about
some of the standings after this game
but you know a lot of things has
happened if I should be defeated the
Magnus Carlsen already in this
tournament which cost cousin to lose the
lead in this tournament and now he faces
a Peter Svidler so we do have some
photos before this game and today is a
rest day in Norway championship so the
players are unlike last year they had
you know they drove tractors had a
milking they were milking cows and you
know things like that and now they are
having a cooking contest but you know
there are I will show some pictures from
that event and you know even some videos
but tomorrow before round 4 but photos
we could want to check it out
immediately feel free to follow the
Norway Championship Twitter account they
will they will have a lot of photos and
videos but now let's check out some of
the photos from this game here we have
even took preparing himself for this
round against wheeler you can see when
Chuck chilling with with the crowd
before every game you know he's a man of
the people
oh sorry then we have a Peter Svidler I
even used this photo to update his
profile for one on the left as it's a
it's a very elegant photo and he appears
to be combat ready so I really like it
and if you really focus there will
appear three a blurry event you in the
background also a very nice detail to
the photo so then we have a nice
close-up of Eve and Chuck you can see
that wristwatch on his hand it's very
you know it's very tight so for someone
obsessed with time he really gets into
time trouble a lot then we have another
nice close-up of Eve and Chuck really
that that man really knows how to pose
under right there is a photographer I'm
unable to identify
five and on the left there appears to be
a Wilder job of lurking so that's
basically it and we will not be showing
the Kramnik versus gelfand game which
ended in a draw so that's again not a
reason not to show a nice engagement
photo so there is Boris Gelfand waiting
for his game against Vladimir Kramnik
wood with his espresso as usual so those
were the photos I do hope you enjoyed
them and now let's check out the game
it's a very nice game because sweedler
opened with e4 and eventual counters
with the French defense so we have e 6 d
4 D 5 and E 5 the advanced variation of
the French c5 c3 Knight to c6 and the
knight to f3 the Polson attack Bishop to
d7 Bishop e2 we have Knight G to e7
castles knife to g6 and now g3 you can't
immediately kick away the night using h4
because the Queen and Knight are
guarding h4 so g3 and now C captures on
d4 we have C capture some before and now
f6 f6 is a very nice move and the French
is one of those openings where it's
actually ok to play f6 in most of the
lines so if you're if you're not really
prepared for a certain line and someone
plays f6 in the French you know just
capture that point which is watch what's
with this wheeler does it captures on f6
we have Coonan captures on f6 and now
here you can watch an interview with
Peter Svidler after this game he says
that he plays Bishop to g5 for you know
the purpose of asking questions what is
he want to explain and what does he want
you want to do so Queen to f7 and Bishop
back to e3 so not really interested in
keeping his Bishop and g5 we have h6
Knight to c3 and the Bishop to d6 now
and here are very interesting move by
Peters wheeler which really does show
how far his imagination goes he plays
Knight to b5 and you might think okay
that's a weird move to play you want to
of course plays Bishop to be 8 and the
what did White achieve here next move a
six will be played then the knight has
to go back everyone loses a temple
Bishop goes back and
you know nothing really happening here
but the problem is a swindler looked
looked much further than this of course
he plays Knight to e5
it's a pawn sacrifice which similar says
that you don't have to play this but if
you don't play it then you're gonna
probably regret it for the rest of the
game you're gonna have a passive
position and you're gonna think I could
have just sacrificed a pawn and have a
nice game so he does it Knight to e5
we have Knight G captures on e5 pawn
captures and now Knight captures on e5
and Bishop to c5 and now you can see
that white has excellent compensation
for upon he's preventing black from
castling Knight to d6 is coming
threatening of course the fork the king
and queen but black will of course
capture and white will win the bishop
repair
so definitely a nice compensation for
the pawn I will have Knight to c4 by von
Schuch guarding d6 and now b3 s wheeler
forces you want you to move his night
away so nice to d6 check can be played
but he went to refuses and he goes b6
now of course if the knight is captured
then Bishop is captured so first Bishop
to b4 by cellular we have a 5 kicking
the bishop further back and here we have
Bishop to c3 and if I took place Bishop
captures on b5 it is the best move but
it allows Bishop to h5 which attacks the
Queen and the king any 8 so the only
move available to black is actually g6
we have Bishop captures and on h8 this
was the whole point of Bishop to c3g
captures on h5 and now you can see that
if one chip does have two pieces for the
rook and be captures on c4 can
definitely be played but after Bishop
captures attacking the rook rook e1 and
Bishop to d6 s wheeler thought that even
troops bishop pair will be compensation
enough for the exchange better up the c5
is coming then d4 the bishop the bishop
only guarding the e6 pawn nicely and
those bishops will be quite a vicious
attacking the White King so instead
after this gk % h5 move a first
and in-between move rook to e1 a very
powerful move that you know that plunges
event took straight into time trouble
and yes this is yet again another game
where event is in time trouble so what
do you do here B captures on c4 is still
an option
the problem is you don't really have any
good squares for the night the night
can't really move anywhere
if 93 then simply Queen captures on d5
the rook is now attacking e6 the Queen
is attacking the rook on a8 black is
completely lost here so in this position
after after this rook to a one move he
won't move event you play Queen to f5
but it's fair to mention well not fair
but you know definitely interesting that
there is one more move which I'm sure a
player of eventual style and caliber
would find if if not for the time
trouble the move is actually Knight to
d6 and it seems like the idea is the
same if you play Knight to a3 Queen
captures and d5 rook captures on e6 is
coming Queen captures an a8 is coming
but not really this is a very strong
line that was introduced to the players
after the game the engines found this
line after Queen captures on d5 King to
d7 yes simply protecting the e6 pawn and
given up the rook on a eight after Queen
captures then comes Bishop to c6
attacking the Queen and sacrificing yet
another piece so Queen capture some b8
is coming and now
Queen Queen to f3 threatening quincy to
checkmate and queen to h1 checkmate and
it's not all that easy to prevent this
the only move is queen h7 check and
after king c8 queen to a sex check King
moves and now white will have to decide
either to repeat we would check which
will be then a draw by threefold
repetition or white can avoid checkmate
with King to f1 but then white loses the
Queen and it will be it will be an
extremely difficult position to play
after Queen G to check King e2 Bishop to
b5 this checks the king wins the Queen
and after rook rook checks King moves
you know a lot of things are possible
so yeah a very a very interesting
maneuver this this idea quite quite
interesting yeah
after King f1 first
you have to check the King we move check
check and then yeah Roxy one check yeah
I messed up the variation with it
because I put the King here but it
doesn't really matter our black would
definitely have to choose between
threefold repetition and playing this
game queenless well yeah if you would
have two rooks for the Queen laughs you
know everyone would prefer probably
probably the Queen and night here but
again it's very hard to say I wonder who
didn't find it an order nor did he play
it so Queen to a5 was played and now
comes pawn captures finally on c4 Bishop
captures and now Queen to d4
we have Bishop to c7 Bishop to e5
offering a trade and avenge of castles
Queen side here
look 8 2 c1 I putting that rock in front
in front of the king rug d7 and here a
swindler says that after we went to play
this rook to d7 move that he looked away
he was like you know doing doing his
event you think you know probably
staring at the ceiling and fiddler
played a 4 and siedler says that even
though he wanted was in time trouble how
anyone shook looked back at the board
sweedler says that he could see in
eventual size that event couldn't find
the move a sweedler plate you know it
took him like 30 seconds to figure out
that tiller actually played a 4 it's ok
a queen to g4 you want to go first the
trade of Queens Queen to e3 and h4 now
trying to bust open the Kings side Queen
captures in h6 pawn captures g3 pawn
captures g3 and now Bishop to d8 now
with ideas of Bishop attacking on g5 to
attack the Queen and the rook so we have
Bishop to f4 preventing this and also
now the Queen and rook are both
attacking the e6 pawn we have rook to e7
this does defend the pawn but it will
lose the exchange Bishop to g5 King to
d7 Bishop captures Bishop captures and
King to g2 we have Bishop to d6 and now
f3 Queen to a5 and after Queen to g7
this was check and they want to cast a
move the king but it was in this
position on move 37 3 moves B before
in time control vastly one shook yet
again lost the game on time of course
it's a better position for swimmer he
has two rooks against the bishops pair
and although the two rooks are not very
active the bishops are controlling the
board very nicely still it's a better
position for white and in time most
likely sweedler would win this but yeah
this is the fifth game in this
tournament vastly once you've lost on
time and you know it's quite quite quite
amazing you know you play the candidates
and you lose five games on time you know
I actually I actually thought event you
would maybe qualify for the 2018
candidates tournament and he did almost
reach it he was kicked out of the World
Cup when he played against eleven Oregon
but yeah he was he was very close but if
he didn't play then you know if he
played then R&L wouldn't play so you
know it's it's not everyone can play but
I'm sure everyone's will you know keep
playing and he will probably play in the
World Cup and qualify perhaps for the
next candidate so maybe we'll see more
of you want you in the next candidates
tournaments so yeah that's the game I do
hope you enjoyed it and let's check out
the define the standings before the
final round so cross and corrupt allowed
me to Kramnik it's eight and a half
points for both of them and then follows
Oregon in silver with seven so in the
final round regardless of how any game
goes only Carlson and cronic can win the
candidates tournament so not a lot of
people in the race only two of them and
Carson has a better additional criteria
he has more wins than chronic even
though they have the same amount of
points so chronic has to have more
points so definitely he should either
win and cross and draw or he should draw
in course and lose and as you know as
you know the drama would have it
Carson faces Peter Svidler in the last
round and a lot more chronic faces none
other than vastly event you in the last
round and even Chuck said after this
game against wheeler that he lost some
time he says they asked him what are
your expectations or your plans in your
games against like chronic and he was
like I'm not really interested you know
it's just
the game better better would be to
prepare for my next tournament the the
Russian championship so yeah that's the
game once again I do hope you enjoyed it
I would like to thank Jack Crow met Bill
Ray
Ava's Allah Muhammad Damien tattoo and
Eugene English teacher for a
contribution to my channel thank a lot I
really appreciate it as usual you can
check two of my previous videos here
thank all for watching and I will see
you soon today with with another game
from the final round of the 2013
candidates tournament thank you all and
see you soon